if I'm being honest I'm feeling I mean
it's charting everyone's talking about
it
what's it feel like I honestly it's the
most surreal thing in the world because
I have just been sitting on this song
for so long and I'm it's just been so
terrified to do anything with it and I
finally just got the courage to be like
look the lyrics are relatable right now
for a lot of people I wrote it in a time
where I was like connected to a lot of
pain and hurt in the case anymore so I
was like uh what do I really want to
release it and then now given the times
I'm like we can all relate to the lyrics
and it's gonna do it because isolation
and everything that's going on has
taught me that like time is so valuable
and it's important and don't want to
like go on through life without being
like with or having any you know like
why not what if that whole thing so I'm
like why not
and so I did it and the response I think
I had in my head like well I'm not
Carrie Underwood and I'm not like this
you know Nashville country star so
people are gonna kpop I do
I threw his squeak toy up there because
I didn't when I'm squeaking and he
jumped up and now he's trouble that's
amazing okay that is so funny oh I love
it
okay okay you're saying you're not like
Carrie Underwood however I would
disagree you're certainly on your way
like you're incredible so go ahead I
can't hit those Carrie Underwood notes
but but I just was like stop doing that
comparison thing Caitlyn and like
peoples response I think they were
really genuinely just like listening to
the lyrics and everybody was so
supportive so now I just feel it does
the long-winded answer to how do you
feel but I feel so overwhelmed with joy
and I'm proud of myself
and I'm just like like humbled it all
swamps to it
niya and I play it all the time we love
it it's so good thank you so what are
you gonna do for the music video I mean
listen I know you can
music video on the beach I think you
should take a bunch of girls yeah and
everybody sings it on a beach you saying
just say yeah you know what any excuse
to get to a beach right now would be it
would be great we'll see what happens I
was thinking like sitting in the middle
of a room with an acoustic guitar and
just like no makeup and just like
drinking wine and just make it like raw
and vulnerable also very good but no
that's the beach sounds a lot better
yeah exactly so I mean I also if I'm
being honest I heard you saying that
isolating with your boyfriend is amazing
but that you didn't want an engagement
during isolation right so bad I you know
some say it's romantic but what okay
tell me your reasoning of to know you
don't want it during quarantine nobody's
ever asked me for a reason now I'm like
wait why don't I want a quarantine
engagement I think because I always said
I wanted a more private engagement and
what's more private than isolation so I
guess I wouldn't be mad
could you imagine he does it I'm like no
I obviously say yes it'd be so excited
but I think I just picture like we're
just here doing our every day today I
just don't know where or how he would do
it but I always just keep envisioning
like a beach so I'll act like nothing
yeah back to the beach
I don't know I'm I don't I'm not that
picky
now that you've questioned me on it I'm
like okay I don't care as long as yeah I
get it
so how are you feeling these days I mean
you meant you know you talked about
being in your house and the two of you
are there with your pops and stuff and I
know that you're open with your anxiety
which helps so many other people how are
you dealing with your anxiety and
everything's going on yeah it's been can
you hear him squeaking the story again
it's amazing it's it's been like I think
maybe a lot of people can relate to this
if just like each day is different like
some days I wake up and I'm like writing
in my gratitude journal and I'm like
today's gonna be a great day and I
FaceTime friends
I get so much work done I'm being
productive and the other days I'm like I
don't want to get out of bed I feel
depressed what I'm gonna see family
again my my parents at my mom and my
stepdad are in Mexico my other dad and
my stepmom are in Canada my sister and
my niece and nephew are in Canada and
it's that's crossing borders and it's
just like I get really anxious about
when I'll be able to see them but I
think it's all about perspective and
some days I have good perspective
some days I have none at all so it's
it's day-to-day over here ya know I get
that and yoga's helping I here helping
you stay centered and yes so I actually
got an assistant because I was feeling
so answering to so many different people
and everything I have going on that I
got an assistant and she's also a yoga
instructor and so on my like Tuesdays
and Sundays I try and make my days off
and she'll like come over and do like
yoga class in the morning for me and
it's really helped that's good and your
I thought I thought you spinning in a
corner
you're blocking off the doctor that is
another thing that I do to keep myself
sane as the spin classes on a peloton
are like life-changing like the
instructors I mean I'm in love with one
of the instructors just like he's just
like it's like a therapy class while
you're exercising the way he speaks to
your soul it's amazing Wow okay that is
that's an ADD right there he speaks to
my soul I love that that's so good what
is your um what is your family think of
you're single and they must be blown
away the yeah my sister is my sister has
always just been such a supporter and so
proud of me and everything that I do and
she just like she said she's been so
emotional she was playing iTunes radio
and it just like came on and she just
she cried and I was on FaceTime with my
mom when it actually came out and she
was like one of the first people to buy
it on iTunes and my dad was actually in
the studio with me while I was recording
that because I was going through the
breakup with Sean at the time it was a
really really hard time and so my dad
was there with me and kind of helping me
and I'm like he was like let's go do
this together because the song came out
or no sorry I recorded the song they
came out about our breakup so I was
having a really hard day and I was gonna
ask that is the song specifically about
the breakup or is it a bit yes yeah I
mean it was kind of a bunch of things I
think people were starting to like
question the relationship and I had a
lot of online negativity coming my way
and I was just kind of going through a
hard time all together so it's kind of
about a bunch of things but it was that
was such a hard day to get out of bed
and go like record a song sure I just
was a I have to prove to myself how
resilient I am and my dad helped so much
and so he was in the studio so for it to
all come together and be out there and
and have him know he was there with me I
recorded he's obviously so proud yeah
has he heard it do you know
Michonne heard it a lot of I have no
idea I know he's heard it like obviously
like when I was holding on to it a long
time ago I showed him men but I have no
idea if he's heard at or not know click
so you wrote it you wrote the whole
thing you brought that on yourself I
know I cannot take all the credit
I was with co-writing with writers in
Nashville oh wow I have no idea how to
write a song so I'm like I I know I'm a
good storyteller I know I have a lot of
so I obviously wrote it but I had
co-writers that did like the music and
helped with the songwriting because I
have no idea how to like put songs
together or you know format wise though
that's up to the professionals so um
it's co-writing yup well you did a great
job by me for not knowing it's really
and how long did you write it though I'm
about a year just over a year and a half
ago Wow when you sat on it for that long
yeah but I mean everything happens for a
reason right like it's true you're in
the right place timing is everything and
it just felt like the right time and
when I wrote it I didn't want to feel
sad and the hurt and I had bounced back
quick and everything was going well and
I I don't know why because my whole
thing is I love releasing anything
that's going to help other people
and I just wasn't thinking that I was
just being so insecure about sharing my
voice and now I've just been feeling
more inspired to write more and sing
more and and share other parts of my
story so is there an EP coming or what's
the story glory the property I actually
said I have already recorded but I've
got some writing sessions coming up with
some people in Nashville here so I'm
yeah obviously excited excited now I'm
just I feel motivated to tonight you
have to keep it going because we're all
wanting more so don't don't leave your
people hanging like you need stuff okay
we need we need some more a couple more
bops I hope you get I'm like was that
just a one here or like where do I go no
no that was not a one-hit wonder you
have an incredible voice obviously very
talented and you can write so no keep
going girl with all the things that
you're doing it's amazing thank you yeah
it's it's I just I know I said this last
time we talked about I just feel so
grateful and so thankful that I can do
the things that I love to do from home
and be healthy and and all of that so
perspective perspective well I mean the
other thing before you go
how's your youtube series going oh so
good it's it's so challenging because I
am doing everything by myself so I'm
like setting everything every time like
I don't know if I'm doing audio right or
like I props to you for obviously you're
doing the same thing at home right now
and just you know having people in zooms
and a producer and setting up lighting
and audio and everything and then trying
to get the dogs to stay quiet and then
get out of the house and yeah thing
going on but it's it's been really fun
to just have another platform to connect
to people because you know obviously on
social media you're just seeing little
snippets here and there but a YouTube
has given me an opportunity to just like
dive a little deeper into things and be
able to just share other things that
people might not know or other things
that relate to or maybe like the
behind-the-scenes of why I am so nervous
to share my music and just going a
little deeper into who I really am well
we love it and we love you so things
Oh bug nicely blooper reels because that
was incredible I think so oh my gosh I
could hit the top of my roof of my mouth
and I was like okay anyway who ended
there because there's nothing more no
that was incredible
okay guys thank you for always being so
supportive oh we love you so much and
just continued success and and we'll see
you in person soon oh I hope so